and joining us now white house press
secretary jen
saki jen welcome back to fox news sunday
thank you chris thanks for having me on
this morning
president biden has taken to asking
critics of his coveted relief bill what
would you cut
the nonpartisan congressional budget
office says that
more than one-third of the total bill
700 billion dollars would not be spent
this year but would be spent between
2022 and 2020
2031. so how does that qualify
as covet relief
well first chris the focus of the
package is getting direct checks to the
american people
getting vaccines in the arms of
americans and ensuring
that people who need help at this very
difficult time can get it
but people also have to plan schools
have to plan to reopen they need to do
budgetary planning over the course of
years
businesses need to do that as well so
this package is meant to of course
provide
immediate direct relief but also provide
a bridge to help us all get through this
crisis
but let's take one specific area that
you just mentioned schools
the bill would give 170 billion dollars
to schools
from elementary through college but the
cbo
projects that 95 of that money
again won't be spent this year but will
be spent from 2022
through 2028 and let me drill down even
further
480 million dollars of the coveted
relief bill according
to the cbo would go to the arts
humanities
museums libraries again what does that
have to do with emergency
covert relief and getting kids back into
school
this year
first of all uh the 90 of this package
goes to address the twin crises we're
facing right now chris which is
getting the pandemic under control and
helping the american people
go back to work helping them get the
relief they need to get through this
period of time
schools are like businesses chris they
need to budgetary plan over a period of
time
some have to front load changes whether
it's to their facilities or ensuring
that if they
have to hire additional teachers or bus
or bus drivers at this point we're
talking about make sure that we're
talking about
that well they have to plan over the
period of time i'm sure i don't want my
kids to be going to school where they
have to fire teachers next year
or won't have to be able to do the
facilities facility upgrades i should
say
necessary in order to ensure they're
going to school safely
that's exactly what is included in this
package
uh let me turn to another subject about
the bill now that the senate
parliamentarian has ruled that the
15 dollar minimum wage does not qualify
under the budget rules some senate
democrats are talking about either using
tax incentives or tax penalties
to get corporations and small businesses
to go there as part of the coveted
relief bill
does the president support that
well i think you're referring to senator
sanders proposal chris and we have not
yet reviewed that proposal but the
senate
the president supports exactly what
senator sanders does which is
increasing the minimum wage for the
american people for workers who are just
trying to make ends meet
and he thinks that's long overdue we're
going to have to spend the next several
days or even weeks figuring out what the
best path forward is but he's committed
to doing that
you also had a busy week in foreign
policy and i want to talk about that
during the campaign
candidate biden said that he promised to
crack down on saudi arabia
for the murder of jamal khashoggi here
he is
we were going to in fact make them pay
the price and
make them in fact the pariah that they
are there's very little social redeeming
value
of the in the present government in
saudi arabia
and on friday u.s intelligence agencies
released this report
we assess that saudi arabia's crown
prince mohammed bin salman
approved an operation in istanbul turkey
to capture or kill saudi journalist
jamal khashoggi
couple of questions jen does the
president
still believe as he did back in november
of
2019 that the crown prince was
personally responsible personally
ordered the murder of jamal khashoggi
and if he does why didn't he move to act
against mbs personally
well the president believes this was a
horrific crime
and uh what we saw outlined in the
unclassified report released as you
referenced chris
is confirmation of the details of this
crime some that we've known for some
time
and the president put what was an
advocate for releasing that
and abiding by our legal obligations let
me be very clear though we
we took specific actions on friday our
objective
is to recalibrate our relationship we've
already taken steps to do that
make sure it's not a continuation of the
last four years and prevent the horrific
act that happened
to our to journalists jamal khashoggi
from ever happening again
that's why we put sanctions through the
treasury department
on the deputy head of the intelligence
department why we sit why we
under the magnitsky act designated the
saudi inter
intelligence forces why we've taken very
specific steps chris to make sure
we're sending a clear message to the
world and that that's what we announced
on friday
but but it isn't a clear message in 2019
the president in a democratic debate
said that he believed that mbs the crown
prince
personally ordered the murder of
khashoggi
uh that's what his intelligence report
says i'm asking you now
does he personally believe that
that mbs ordered the assassination of
khashoggi
and if he does why not penalize him he
sanctions a bunch of other people he
doesn't sanction the crown prince
well first let me be clear that behind
the scenes there are a range of
diplomatic conversations that make
absolutely clear to the saudis and to
others around the world
that this is going to be a different
kind of relationship and our actions
make
that absolutely clear as well chris
historically though as you all know
you've been covering these issues for
some time
the united states has not historically
sanctioned the
leaders of countries where we have
diplomatic relations or even some where
we don't have diplomatic relations
we understand that's a bar some are
holding this too but our objective here
from the government from the biden
administration
is preventing this from ever happening
again i should also know we also
announced the khashoggi rule
which gives power to the secretary of
state to be able to to prevent
uh foreigners who have uh who have shown
that they are going to threaten
dissidents or journalists
from traveling on a visa to the united
states this is a global issue
and one we're going to be clear in
sending a message about both privately
and publicly chris
i am running out of time and i got a
couple of questions i really need to ask
you
uh the president also ordered a military
strike in eastern syria this week
against iranian-backed militias
is he sending a message that there is a
link
between an iran nuclear deal and iran's
activities in the region
that there can't be an agreement there
can't be successful diplomacy
at the same time that iranian-backed
forces are
attacking u.s personnel
chris he's sending an unambiguous
message that he's going to protect
our men and women serving and our
coalition forces and that's exactly what
he did with this strike
in terms of the iranian nuclear deal we
believe that the best path is a
diplomatic path forward we want to
prevent
iran from acquiring a nuclear weapon
that's in our national interest that's
in the global national interests
where that sits now as we're waiting the
europeans are waiting to hear back from
the iranians on whether they will sit at
the table
and have that discussion but the the
strike this week
was specifically about responding to
threats and attacks that were
threatening our troops and our men and
women serving overseas
the president or the rather the biden
administration this week reopened a
migrant
facility for children that was used
under president trump and that unleashed
a
storm of criticism as you know
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
tweeted this is not okay never has been
okay
never will be okay no matter the
administration or party now you have
distinguished between what you admit you
are doing and what the trump
administration is doing i'm asking you a
different question though
isn't the biden administration
contributing to this crisis by reversing
the trump policy which called for
immediately returning
uh migrant children who across the
country unaccompanied children who cross
the border
uh by themselves their
border patrol officials are saying that
you are
creating a surge and that by may we
could see
a bigger surge than we saw during the
worst moments of the 2019
crisis on the border
well chris the vast majority of families
and adults are turned away at the border
this is not the time to come and we have
been
very clear about that but our approach
from the biden administration
is that we think the most humane step we
can take here
is to have these children unaccompanied
kids under 18
not not send them back to take a
treacherous path forward this is a
difficult choice
but that's one that we felt was the the
right one the most humane one
because these are kids they're fleeing
prosecution they're fleeing difficult
circumstances in their country
and our objective is to treat them
humanely and to keep them safe
and the reason i should say that we
opened this facility is because of covid
chris as you know
and that's why it's open because we want
to keep these kids safe including at a
time where we're facing a pandemic
but aren't you by changing the policy
aren't you encouraging
some of these young people to come which
means you're going to have a bigger
crisis on the border
well chris we've been unambiguous and
very being and clear in the region this
is not the time to come
and this is a difficult choice for
everyone but as a mother as a parent
i'm not going to support not nor would
the president sending kids under 18 some
at the age of 11 12
13 back on a treacherous trip across the
border to face persecution
and difficult circumstances in their
country these kids are coming alone
and this is a this is the choice we've
made because we feel it's humane and we
feel
safe the vast majority of any family
that's coming together
any adults that's coming are turned away
at the border
because we have not had time to put in
place comprehensive immigration policies
yet at this point in time finally
when will the white house pull the
nomination of nira tanda
to be the budget director
well chris we remain committed to
fighting our hearts out for near
tandon we believe she is the right
person she's qualified she's experienced
to lead
the budget department she brings unique
experience as somebody who's lived
through
uh benefiting from a number of these
programs and she's worked on these
issues for decades
across the aisle so we're going to keep
fighting for it we knew that some of
these fights would be difficult
and this is certainly one of them but
she's going to have a number of
continued engagements this week and we
are certainly hopeful we can get it
across the finish line
jen there was lots to talk to you about
you guys made a lot of news this week
thank you thanks for joining us
you too